ポンちゃん肇社長です皆さん筋トレしたことありますでしょうか
僕はも全然近所になんでここ最近まったくしないんですけど高校のバス9分経ったとき
に結構筋トレしてましてかなぜ結構キープでしたらこういうレンチプレって言うから
多いこれありますよね
発送
ラベルこれ良子寝そべってこういう奴はバーベルって言うんですけどめっちゃお前じゃ
ねえ
めっちゃ重いバーベルなボク多分結構雨旅行行ってやっててこそ
ほどの人がいたんですけどパーンと落ちてきて重すぎてなんか違うな素敵な持ち上がら
なくて首のここでバーベルこうなって1回死にかけたことがあって結構バーベル僕の中
の公園のランキング道
上位にあります本当声ですマヴェル思いし怖いですよそんな恐ろしいバーベル空が準備
しました
こちら雲よ
では今の机が折れそうで心配ですあげましょう
ああああああ
最需要期が出てきましたバーベル120キロです
すぐめっちゃくちゃオーレがたくさん入ってめちゃくちゃ重いように出かけて a
ずだそれ
偽物です
実はこの偽物でございますお守りの数からみて相当重そうなんですよ
これで俺の候補ずらいの記憶をたどると大体これだけ覚えがたくさんついてるぞ
百人勇者があるんではないかなと相当相当ついてるんだって
でこれ
めっちゃ軽いです嬢さんに頼んでめっちゃくちゃ重そうに見えるめちゃくちゃ軽い
バーベルを付けて下さいって言っていました
ちゃんとホテルには初めというロゴ入りでございますこのマーベル何がすごいかといい
ますと例えば僕がこれで一生懸命金取りをしているとこうやって
[音楽]
やってるとこれが存在を知らない人からすると俺気になるわけですよ
こんな滅茶苦茶ものの120キロ中からまあれるをいとも簡単にこうやって
こいつは吠えちゃってやってるとそれはもう怖いわけですよまして
町からこんな102絶景の場面を持って入ってどーってこ
使いそうになったらの恐怖でクルー
んああああああ
というわけでめっちゃもそうなバベルがめっちゃ軽いドッキリ行ってみようと思います
今始めミューズメッツパークに人がいると思うんですけども
とりあえずまずバレないかどうか確認したいってはいけない僕が思うにこんなバーグで
珍鳥してるか
なんかこうなんか持ち上げて凍って年間アクシデントでとって落として誰かに課すして
みようと思います
時のリアクションほとんどリアクションを集めてみたいなって
ございますねあなたもうほんとになんだこれでやめろっつってなんかどうずぶつかっ
たりしたりするとどんな反応するのか
120キロのバーベルが住んで来ると怖いですよねこの取って指をしたいがために
まずまた業者に特注で発注して作ってもらいました
田爪バーベルでございます
生んではいくんっ
[音楽]
通夜ははっはっは
はい
野望
ええええええ
あ経営者についてないという
心配してませんがあっちゃ
やばやばいああ
どうやって持ってきたんですか
やるぞと思った
ああいうよ
[音楽]
はぁ
やっぱり家壊れそうで心配なんだけど多分120
高まる
[音楽]
やってい
ん
えまってこれ始めって書いてあるん
カラーああっ
場所
それはそうしてポスターあります
第じゃないやばかった理由はやるっ
補助タンクやばいよも殺せないけどで建造する
ちょっといいんじゃねよぼよぼ予防効果を持つ
いや
おかしいそれじゃあ範囲内門力
これ絶対ごめん権五キロだ
あれもえっいやー今プレーンどれガッチャ思うじゃんガッチャ思い者が釣れんもういい
じゃん
がちだオフィスやすっ
[音楽]
ヤクザ越王子消費者センター序文
さああああ
米軍が月限はガチでもう
120キロはいっ
これ
ううっえっ
faa 度できるわけなんですよね
これってヤバイでまずでただ一人者の10年目
あったこんななかった全10キロが勝っていません
横屋さんもいらっしゃったただついて釣ってもらっ
[音楽]
持ち上がらないんですよためですよねの右腕と苦痛だとほどほど補助だろうか
おっさんの赤瀬こそ約120てやバイク仲間いてますちゃんと
いや大丈夫2
いや無理だいやマジあべまじゃない
うん
デコレどうやってカットのが失敗やバカですよ
どっちもって下沿いぬっ
[音楽]
できるじゃあ俺がヤバイこれいっ
でも66中持ち上げればって考えだからやって多く自然津別きついぞ越谷前越谷が与え
立たずこっちのられてる子次男が精一杯なんです岩佐カウンター
[音楽]
幸田公があって
ああ
盛って食べますかてアジアっていうのがいいのかえっじゃあ
ああああああああ
着にスキル名でずっキロドッキリでした
[音楽]
始め
良いじゃあなんで
ちょっとだ次へ
ランプ月でアンダーやってなんか
周辺月その他分いいじゃないか3年じゃないと思っちゃうねええふいーじゃん66十分
だったわー
ああああああああ
car
uh
me
car
あっはぁ
igu ね違うても私はそう言ってこないためにはそれでもいいんですよ
はい忘れてこれはいはいはいね
うぇい
her ear
よね